in our first story google had a massive
earnings beat for q2 2021 yesterday and
youtube grew revenue almost 100
year-over-year 80 year-over-year growth
is just extraordinary for a large
business let's break down how youtube
compares to
netflix two seemingly very different
businesses but who line up kind of
interestingly so uh just to give you
some background you know that alphabet
is the pairing company of google they
named it alphabet so that every letter
of the alphabet could be a different
unit cynically uh what most people think
is they created alphabet
so that there would be no way for larry
and sergey to get dragged to washington
dc or to the eu and face all kinds of
different regulatory organizations they
wanted it to be a conglomerate a holding
company and put somebody in charge of it
and so now poor sundar has to contract
in front of congress that's a cynical
take uh that everybody kind of knows is
the truth uh is that the founders wanted
to be lower profile and mission
accomplished uh you see zuck getting
dragged all over the world and uh you
see bezos is no longer in the top spot
this is now the new technique
for founders to put somebody else in the
driver's seat and maybe they get to not
take as many arrows or be annoyed by
being dragged around the world like
zuckerberg has been to face the music uh
so total q2 revenue 61.8 billion up 62
year-over-year now just let that sink in
you know we've talked a lot about how in
startups we're looking for startups that
grow 20 a month and that are growing
three x year over year that's kind of
when these things are starting out what
you're looking for when you hit scale
and you've got tens of billions of
dollars in revenue understand that
sixty-two percent growth on tens of
billions of dollars is a ton of revenue
so much so the first half revenue is 117
billion
and if you just double that you know
you're getting to over 230 billion and
obviously it's going to keep growing so
this is a footprint of revenue unlike
anything we've seen you know prior to
with the exception of apple and
microsoft and amazon the net income
was 18.5 billion dollars that's the
profit that's what they put in their
bank account and that's up 2.6 x
year-over-year in other words they were
massively profitable so at this pace
they will put 73 billion dollars into
their uh bank account this year that is
a lot of cash with that money they could
buy coinbase just with one year's
profits they could buy airbnb uber
doordash any number of assets right but
in this country now we have been putting
the kibosh on m a and looking at these
companies that are getting so big
with a little bit of a a tighter amount
of scrutiny and
this is in the face of china
ankling their own companies reversing
them going public pulling their apps out
of the app store
forcing high-profile founders not to
maybe give up their seat
uh voluntarily but maybe putting a gun
to their head who knows quite literally
perhaps
to get them to uh neuter their own
companies it's crazy when you think
about it so
uh youtube
is a major driver here but google search
business and their third-party ed
network is what google is google is an
ad business at its core that's how they
make their money and their ad revenue
was 50 of that 61 billion dollars
now remember q2 of 2020 was really hard
hit by covid
and advertising dollars did dry up for a
little bit people pause their ad buys
everybody if you remember just a year
ago
in a couple of months people were in a
full scale panic what would happen to
the economy a lot got frozen during that
time
um so
the year every year growth could be a
little inflated here
but retail was by far the largest
contributor to the company's ad growth
according to their chief business
officer
phillip schindler on tuesday's earning
call uh google's cloud is becoming uh
you know almost 10 of their revenue 4.6
billion that's really interesting so
google's cloud computing platform which
goes up against amazon web services and
they've also cut their losses for google
cloud by 840 million year over year they
lost 1.4 billion in q2 of last year and
this quarter they only lost 591 million
when you say losses another way to frame
that in your mind is investment so
they've been investing trying to catch
up to amazon web services and compete in
cloud computing also with microsoft's
azure those are the top three players
and so
you see them investing in that business
and it's apparently paying off despite
all this uh the most impressive business
in q2 was youtube their ad revenue was 7
billion up 83 year-over-year
and this doesn't include subscription
revenue which uh alphabet doesn't
disclose for youtube for some reason but
they are disclosing youtube's revenue
separately which they they didn't do for
a long time uh and when you look at it
it's pretty close to uh the seven
billion is pretty close to netflix's q2
revenue which was 7.3 billion i think
it's great for us to look uh at these
two businesses netflix has 10 times less
users than youtube they only have 210
million subscribers compared to
youtube's 2 billion plus users who use
the service every month so one is ten
percent of the size of the other
they both have the same revenue and the
revenue comes from different places so
if if you look at where the content
comes from what what is the product well
netflix netflix spends billions on
premium content every year we know that
and they have to develop their own ip
now because other ip holders are pulling
their content off the platform remember
netflix had all those marvel deals for
daredevil and punisher and all that kind
of stuff that all got pulled right and
all those series are now on disney plus
netflix spent close to 12 billion on
content in 2020 and they're going to
spend
17 billion in 2021 according to variety
youtube has billions of users obviously
and it's generally user generated
content or professional generated
content but it's an open platform
youtube is not a gatekeeper anybody can
upload anything uh they want to youtube
and and they do right podcasts
youtube creators how-to articles
but youtube paid 30 billion dollars to
creators from 2018 through 2020 and uh
that was from the 2021 yearly priority
letter from susan wojecki who i'd love
to have on the program by the way we
should we should invite susan to come on
the program again so if you look at the
content business one person has to spend
a god awful amount of money the other
one just gives a percentage it's it's
kind of a jump ball there it's two
different things i wouldn't give the
edge to either company you know one of
them owns a hundred percent of the ip in
most cases that's netflix and in
youtube's case they don't own this ip uh
you know anybody can take their content
off or stop publishing it there like we
saw joe rogan do so you might even give
the edge uh to netflix if they happen to
figure out how to create a franchise
like star wars or marvel in the future
which they might uh they might be able
to do that uh orange is the new black is
probably not it but there might be
others so if you look at the strength of
the revenue
and the quality of that revenue well
netflix has subscription revenue and and
that is usually more predictable than ad
based revenue however netflix did have a
number of users unsubscribed or not
renew in the last quarter they lost
about 400 000 folks
so
uh youtube's revenue
could be fickle because advertising you
know does go up and down based on the
economy however when you hit scale you
have to ask yourself who's the
competitor here right who's the
competitor to youtube a massively global
business that has never existed before
and i would actually even though
subscription revenue is delightful and
predictable i'd actually give the edge
to youtube here because i don't think
they have a contemporary there is no
business out there that can reach as
many people as quickly with video than
youtube so if you're a tv advertiser and
you want to reach 100 million people 500
million people is there a network that
can do that today can nbc do that no can
disney do that no there is not a network
who can do that except for youtube
in today's startup landscape committing
to security and compliance is vital for
growth and proof of your company's
security posture has never been more
important as you scale you might start
to receive more sock 2 requests from
customers and that's where drata comes
in trada is an advanced automation
platform used by some of the world's
leading chief information security
officers or csos strata will help you
successfully meet requirements support
enterprise deal flow and continually
track compliance drata also helps
customers easily prepare for and clear
sock 2 and other audits so you can go
from zero to audit ready in a matter of
weeks need more take it from philip
martin chief security officer at
coinbase and here's his quote it became
clear to me right away that drata is an
engineering powerhouse the solution
they've developed is well ahead of other
market players their approach to deep
native integrations provides users with
the most advanced automation available
so check out drata's five-star reviews
on g2 and see why companies like clearco
smartrecruiter and the good face project
work withdrata for their compliance
needs twist listeners can get
15 off and waived implementation fees at
drata.com twist d-r-a-t-a dot com slash
twist